hallo leute wir sind zurück mit einer
neuen episode aus unserer reihe zu den
deutschen werben und das wär was wir
euch heute vorstellen heißt können
können ist ein besonderes werk in der
deutschen sprache es ist eins der
meistgenutzten werden und es
funktioniert sowohl als vollwert als
auch als hilfswerk als vollwerk steht es
alleine zum beispiel ich kann nichts und
als hilfswerk wird es kombiniert mit
einem infiniti iv zum beispiel ich kann
tanzen und hier seht ihr jetzt 40
beispiele mit können
los geht's
wir fangen an mit der konjugation von
können im präsens ich kann
du kannst er sie es kann
wir können ihr könnt und sie können
janosch kann nichts
janus kann alles wir können das gut ich
kann das nicht kannst du morgen ja ich
kann morgen das waren einige sätze in
denen können als vollwert wird und jetzt
zeigen wir euch einige sätze in denen
können im präsens als hilfswerk benutzt
wird
wir können singen
janisch kann tanzen
kathy kang traurig gucken
[Musik]
du kannst ganz toll gymnastik machen
janus ihr könnt mich alle hören sie
können mich alle nicht hören
jetzt kommen wir zum kriterium als
erstes zeigen wir euch die konjugation
ich konnte du konntest er sie es konnte
wir konnten ihr konntet sie konnten
janosch konnte heute morgen nicht
aufstehen
[Musik]
er konnte einfach nicht die augen öffnen
so müde war er
[Musik]
ich konnte ihn einfach nicht dazu
bewegen aufzustehen
wir konnten nichts zusammen einkaufen
gehen denn janisch schlief noch ihr
könnte diese geschichte bestimmt nicht
glauben jetzt zeigen wir euch die
konjugation imperfekt ich habe gekonnt
du hast gekonnt er sie es hat gekonnt
wir haben gekonnt ihr habt gekonnt sie
haben gekonnt ich hasse tanzen
ich habe das noch nie geträumt
ich habe schon immer sehr laut singen
gekonnt la la la la la
sie hat das noch hinbekommen
jetzt zeigen wir euch die kommunikation
in der zukunft mit werden
ich werde können du wirst können er sie
es wird können wir werden können
ihr werdet können und sie werden können
janosch wird in zukunft noch sehr viel
schlafen können
ich werde in zukunft noch lauter singen
können
janosch wird irgendwann auch tanzen
wenn ihr jetzt noch mehr deutsche werben
lernen wollt dann probiert unbedingt
unsere app siedlung aus dort könnt ihr
das ganze deutsche vokabular von a1 bis
b2 systematisch lernen und ihr könnt
auch gleich die aussprache dazu
trainieren denn auf sie längen haben wir
einen aussprache trainer und da könnt
ihr immer eure eigene aussprache
aufnehmen und abspielen und dann mit der
aussprache eines muttersprachler es zum
beispiel mit meiner aussprache
vergleichen
dadurch werdet ihr schritt für schritt
besser und lernt eure eigene aussprache
selbst zu evaluieren
dankeschön fürs zu sehen bitte abonniert
easy german wenn ihr mehr videos in
zukunft sehen wollt und wir sehen uns
schon am sonntag wieder
[Musik]